[Musik]
sie haben das recht auf leben wir können
in der gleichen schwierigkeit kommen
dass wir mal flüchten müssen und daher
sollte man das nicht vergessen das ist
ein historisch bekannt jeder kann in die
lage kommt das ist man woanders hin muss
und woanders hoffnung hat für sich und
seine kinder
das sollten wir im bewusstsein
hoffentlich
ein moment des innehaltens in bewegenden
zeiten für fahrer sv was braucht es
damit integration auch noch gelingen
kann wenn immer mehr menschen in die
schweiz fliehen und wie versucht eine
gebürtige eritreerin zwischen fremden
kulturen so zu vermitteln dass
gegenseitiges verständnis steht
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
alle asse frau ist viel unterwegs
sie liebt immigranten sich in der
schweiz zu recht zu finden
an diesem tag besucht sie mehrere
eritreischer asylsuchende in einer
zürcher gemeinde die mittvierzigerin
kann sich gut in ihrer lage versetzen
als flüchtlingskind sie einst selbst in
der fremde auf in deutschland nun lässt
sie sich die unterkunft zeigen um
herauszufinden wie die
lebensverhältnisse der frauen sind haben
sie einen rückzugsort privatsphäre die
nötige kleidung den rahmen um ihrer
gesundheit sorge zu tragen
mit solchen fragen prüft phase v ob die
voraussetzungen geschaffen sind dass
sich die menschen wohlfühlen können wenn
ja ist ein erster schritt zur
integration getan
die gemeinde die diese unterkunft stellt
begleitet die bewohner england lässt
sich jedoch nicht vermeiden zu belastend
sind oft alltag und biografie der
neuankömmlinge
was löst das in ihnen aus diese
wohnsituation die wohnsituation die
geschichten der frauen macht mich sehr
betroffen
ja zum beispiel greift die eine frau
erzählt dass ihr mann abgeschoben wird
im gefängnis so zu sagen ja und sie
befürchtet eben aber es eher ausgewiesen
wird
das macht mich sehr betroffen eine
kaffeezeremonie bietet gelegenheit
schmerzhaftes gemeinsam aufzuarbeiten
dazu hat fahne atv drei eritreerin
eingeladen diese schon länger kennt aus
ihrer sprechstunde die
integrationshelferin ist psychiaterin
viele ihrer patientinnen haben auf der
flucht sexuelle übergriffe erlitten oder
in der schweiz verstörendes erlebt etwa
rassismus bei der wohnungssuche
wir brauchen die frauen ziehen da alles
am abgrund linke 90 passieren eben aus
und sie haben so viele leute komisch
die immigranten sind angewiesen auf
vertrauenspersonen die beide kulturen
kennen die ihrige und die schweizerische
an sie können sie sich wenden wenn sie
verunsichert sind verletzt oder
überfordert viele flüchtlinge leiden
unter traumata
darauf hat planer atv mit einer
zusatzausbildung reagiert also ich helfe
den traumatisierten indem ich sie erst
mal ernst nehme mit ihrer geschichten
mit ihrer verletzungen mit ihren
erlebnissen
ich nehme sie erst mal ernst und dann
versuche ich die aktuelle
belastungsfaktoren die sie mir sozusagen
erzielen zu reduzieren helfen also eben
die haben schlecht geboren verhältnis
der gesundheitliche probleme dort
versuche ich an zu setzen
ich kann die vergangenheit nicht
ungeschehen machen aber ich kann
versuchen dass sie lernen damit zu leben
das zu akzeptieren zu integrieren
die eingliederung der asylsuchenden die
gehen beidseitige fahren forderungen wir
ansässigen müssten sie willkommen heißen
sie die sprache lernen und hiesige werte
annehmen ohne die eigenen zu verleugnen
es gibt auch pflicht für die eritrea für
alle flüchtlinge in die schweiz kommen
das heißt aber dass wir ihnen anbieten
müssen damit sie queren können wir
müssten wir müssen sinnvoll anreize
schaffen wo die ästhetischen menschen
sich auch gezwungen können eben schritte
was es heißt mit misstrauen konfrontiert
zu werden weiß fahne acv aus eigener
erfahrung als kleines mädchen lernte sie
früh sich in der fremde zu behaupten
aber auch auf andere zuzugehen um deren
vorurteile abzubauen
an einer veranstaltung der
schweizerischen flüchtlingshilfe tritt
sie als referentin auf ihre stimme hat
in fachkreisen gewicht vor zehn jahren
kam sie aus beruflichen gründen von
berlin in die schweiz
ich spüre sie ist bestens integriert
fanger atv will fremdes näher bringen
damit asylsuchende weder verteufelt noch
realisiert werden
sie könnte die sorge ein land könne an
die grenzen seiner integrations
kapazität stoßen
das verstehe ich sehr gut unsicherheiten
ängste vor allem weil man viele
projektionen hat auf die die kommen man
hat angst dass die arbeitsstellen
wegnehmen
man hat angst dass es eine multi kulti
multikulturelle gesellschaft wird man
hat angst dass die eigenen werte nicht
mehr gelten dass daneben zwei spieler
islam sich ausbreitet oder so so gibt es
eben vorstellungen von menschen mit
denen ich schon gesprochen habe
vorstellungen haben auch in trier
für sie ist die schweiz das land der
träume meine welt und lerne mich
verstehen bezogen auf eritreische
flüchtlinge sie kommen hierher weil sie
gute resilienz haben deren
widerstandskraft
darauf können wir ihnen aufbauen wenn
sie hier ankommen und alles überstanden
haben sind sie verwundert sie haben sich
bis zur ankunft im asylantenheim als
helden erlebt sie haben das unmögliche
geschafft aber ab diesem zeitpunkt geht
es um persönliche und berufliche
perspektive sie hatten ganz hohe
erwartungen und wünsche aber auch viele
projektionen viele geschichten die nicht
realistisch sind
und dann sind sie enttäuscht über die
realität lassen sie uns gastgeber sein
und uns in die lage der menschen
versetzen die unsere hilfe brauchen
ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich für die
aufmerksamkeit
[Musik]
abends geht es zu suchen
dem schweizerischen
unterstützungskomitee für ihre kriege es
unsere pflicht was für menschen zu tun
dass es menschen besser geht deshalb bin
ich auch ärztin
die listerien in der heimat eine zukunft
zu bieten damit sie nicht zur flucht
verleitet werden sollten wir ihn
zukommen lassen
sonst haben wir wirklich alle menschen
aus diesen ländern dann in der schweiz
oder sonst in europa das passiert doch
gerade im moment
wir sind doch alle hier weil sie keine
perspektive haben die perspektiven der
eritrea sind düster weil ihr staaten ist
und eine diktatur so zumindest hat sich
der bundesrat im vergangenen sommer
geäußert das weckt zweifel ob hilfe aus
dem ausland bis zur bevölkerung gelangt
entwicklungshilfe ist möglich in eritrea
es braucht eine gewisse diplomatie und
es braucht eben kompetenz wie man die
menschen dort erreicht das geld muss sie
an die menschen und das ist
gewährleistet trotz dieses regimes also
betreffend suche und die die projekte
die ich jetzt sozusagen mit anreger ist
es gewährleistet ich war selbst in
eritrea vor ort und habe die menschen
dort gesprochen und habe gesehen wie die
projekte tatsächlich umgesetzt werden
fahne atv glaubt an das humanitäre eine
religiöse komponente hat ihr einsatz
nicht sie ist aus der christlichen
kirche ausgetreten
turnierleiter zug seit 40 jahren
engagiert sich der frauenarzt für
eritrea
mittlerweile ist er honorarkonsul des
landes kritiker werfen ihm seine nähe
zum regime vor
er gewichtet die hilfeleistungen höher
finde ich die mannschaft taktisch ich
setze mich hier für die soziale
mannschaft vor dem anpfiff und der
gehrig kann man sie bezüglich in die
westliche gemeinschaft kritisiert
dort hat sie sich richtig finde was sie
im bereich von der sozialen landschaft
macht hervorragend wirklich spur
ich persönlich habe mit den griechen
eben nichts zu tun ich bin in europa
aufgewachsen
wichtig ist mir dass die menschen dort
perspektive haben und dafür setze ich
mich ein
aber sind sie jene freund oder gegner
des regimes weder noch ich habe eben mit
dem regen nichts zu tun ich bin nicht
politisch aktiv sondern humanitär
diese haltung erachten oppositionelle
als mutlos fange atv sie darin wohl ihr
kalkül würde sie sich einmischen geriete
sie ihn ein politisches spannungsfeld
das könnte ihr wirken vor ort gefehlt
an der vorstandssitzung geht es um ein
engagement für hiv-positive strom
diese werden in der patriarchalen
gesellschaft eritrea ausgegrenzt dank
fahne atvs projekt erhalten sie
aufklärung betreuung und ausbildung
finanziell unterstützt durch sce 2013
reiste sie zu den frauen um sich mit
ihnen auszutauschen
sie möchten nicht bemitleidet werden
sie möchten perspektive sie haben
medikamente und sie fühlt sich eben
nicht mehr als aussätzige sie haben
beruf sie können für sich durch regen
oder nähe neben perspektive schaffen
herzlichen dank für das projekt das
bietet so schön vorgestellt hat auszeit
vom alltag mit freundinnen geht zum
bowling
ja hallo zusammen wir haben hier
trotz der teils belastenden begegnungen
im beruf können sie schnell abschalten
sagt farner atv und tatsächlich löst wie
an diesem abend habe ich sie noch nie
erlebt
dennoch behält sie auch hier gerne die
kontrolle die die begründung des
ausflugsziels andeuten könnte
wir haben recht freude zusammen und gibt
strukturen und regeln die man beachten
muss aber trotzdem und deswegen machen
wir berufen welche kultur drückte diese
antwort ihr durch für mich sitzen
schublade eritrea der schublade
europa ist mit allem drum und dran mit
allem verbindende und vermitteln doch
das macht die chance sie vermittelt das
also was die womöglich eigentlich jedem
dass du in vancouver für europa und war
hinterher hund sondern ich erkenne ich
finde sie hat mehr als eine identität
zwischen dem 2 ich habe wirklich auch
nicht elektrisch oder deutsch oder
schweizerisch
also ich kann mit verschiedenen menschen
aus verschiedenen kulturen gut
interagieren
ich habe keine vorurteile wie ich meinen
egal welche sozialisation jemand gehört
oder zu welcher glauben oder welche
bildung stand dass es mir so los
[Musik]
so vermittelt nicht nur zwischen den
nationalitäten sondern auch zwischen den
geschlechtern
wichtig ist aus unserer sicht dass die
männer in verantwortung gezogen werden
müssen betreffen gesundheit
familienplanung kindererziehung und
integration
das ist eben anders als in eritrea dort
herrscht eher patriarchale denken bei
den männern
und hier muss man eben gemeinsam eine
organisation hat sie eingeladen die eng
mit der fachstelle für
integrationsfragen im kanton zürich
zusammenarbeitet workshops sollen
irritieren das denken und handeln näher
bringen das es braucht um in der schweiz
als familie zu funktionieren
hier ist die ehefrau gleichberechtigt
das verunsichert die männer plötzlich
werden ansprüche an sie gestellt etwa im
haushalt zu helfen
mit rollenspielen entkrampft phase v die
stimmung sie will schuldgefühle bei den
teilnehmern vermeiden
gleichzeitig bleibt sie klar in den
aussagen dass sie beide kulturen kennt
verleiht der glaubwürdigkeit selbst bei
den männern die es nicht gewohnt sind
ratschläge von frauen entgegen zu nehmen
[Applaus]
ich bin eine fachperson ich bin eine
frau aber eine fachperson und die sie
sehr offen zu lernen
sie sind zwar tatsächlich erzogen sie
wollen aber nicht unbedingt recht alisch
hier leben sie würden sich gerne
verändern und wissen nicht wie
und da braucht es eben alle selbst
fachliches wissen aber auch eine
kulturelle kompetenz und so erreiche ich
eben die männer zweifel bei der arbeit
kennt fahne atv nicht und wird darin
bestärkt
im thurgauischen littenheid befindet
sich vorne rasse france berufliches
zentrum
hier leitet sie die kinder und
jugendabteilung einer psychiatrischen
klinik als integrationshelferin arbeitet
sie nebenamtlich der zehnjährige ist
einer ihrer patienten schwierigkeiten in
seinem sozialen umfeld setzen ihm arg zu
mittlerweile beeinträchtigt die
angeschlagene psyche gar seinen
bewegungsapparat wie bei den immigranten
bemüht sich fahne atv auch bei ihm um
integration zurück in die gesellschaft
die psychiatrische tätigkeit fordert sie
nicht nur als fachkraft super als mutter
schon kleinen kindern bin ich denke ich
sehr empfänglich dafür dass es mir sehr
nahe geht genau und da versuche ich mich
gut abzugrenzen
aber es bewegt mich sehr und es gibt mir
auch ganz viel kraft dass ich weiß
kinder können auch anders
und da kann ich ihnen ganz authentisch
als mutter aber auch als ärztin die
kinder begegnen und das spüren die
kinder auch in der klinik wo sie oft
vermitteln zwischen eltern und kind juni
zweiter kommt zu besuch hier jedoch
herrscht einigkeit
[Musik]
ja es geht ihm schon viel besser wenn
wir sagen dass für sie so in ordnung ja
gut damit danke ich mich ganz herzlich
danke auch wenn alles sehr gerne und ich
bin froh dass yannick hier sein darf
weiter geht's bereits warten eritreische
asylsuchende im durchgangszentrum
embrach auf wanners ev
gelegenheit ihre eigene familie
kennenzulernen bietet sich mir nicht mit
den beiden kindern und dem ebenfalls aus
eritrea stammenden ehemann aufzutreten
ist ihr zu privat
das verstehe aber bedauerlich denn für
ihre arbeit ist es ja auch zwingend dass
sich die menschen öffnen
knapp 40.000 asylgesuche wurden letztes
jahr in der schweiz gestellt
rund ein viertel stammt von eritrea
sie bilden die größte gruppe in diesem
prüfungsprozess da viele ihrer
landsleute schon hier sind wollen auch
sie in die schweiz wie dieses betagte
ehepaar das seine tochter folgte
integrationswillige müssen hohe hürden
überwinden
psychologische kulturelle berufliche
sprachliche da braucht es manchmal wenig
um sie zu erfreuen
die frau hat gerade gesagt genau das hat
mir gefehlt dass ich mit jemand in
meiner sprache mich austauschen kann und
sie fühlte sich obwohl ich nichts
gemacht habe hatte sie gemeint das tut
mir so gut nach so vielen jahren weil
mich jemand darüber zu sprechen nämlich
versteht oft in das sind die
lebensgeschichten zu
kompliziert als dass ein kurzer
austausch genügt um schwierigkeiten
auszuräumen
wie bei dieser alleinstehenden mutter
wahl erlebt sie schon seit zehn jahren
getrennt und das ist sehr belastend
macht sich ganz viel sorgen um die
kinder sind in eritrea genau fahrgasse
frau macht sich auf zu einem workshop
für junge eritreerin thema
sexualaufklärung und gesundheitsvorsorge
begleiten dürfen wir sie nicht filmen in
den gebäuden ist verboten
impressionen des areals zeigen wie viele
menschen schon in jungen jahren zu
asylsuchende werden
die anzahl der eingereisten
minderjährigen ohne eltern steigt
dennoch an
sie benötigen oft intensive betreuung
die arbeit von phase v wird also wohl
noch zunehmen
ja die große herausforderung bleibt in
der vernetzung es gibt viele
fachpersonen bemüht sind aber die
sollten sich vernetzen und dann ist es
wichtig dass die leute spüren diese
junge frauen dass sie willkommen sind
dass sie das recht haben hier ein teil
von dem wohlstand mit zu bekommen und
gleichzeitig haben sie verpflichtungen
und auch das habe ich ihm versucht eben
näher zu bringen und das ist ihnen auch
bewusst vor augen haben sie die hoffnung
auf ein besseres leben hinter sich eine
meist belastende vergangenheit es ist
ein weg zwischen traum und trauma den
viele hier beschreiten begleitet von
brückenbauern wie feiner sev damit
integration gelingen kann
[Musik]